and we shall begin our evening with Sam
Boyer and his screenplay is ojac the
script Chronicles the moral struggle of
a taxi driver in Jakarta
seeking to build a better life while
engaging in some seriously dangerous
business
Sam is Indonesian and French Canadian he
was galvanized to write ojac in light of
his passion for creating stories about
Outsider characters caught between
cultures
so let's please join me in welcoming Sam
to the stage
[Applause]
thank you
no
Taste of things to come
hey y'all uh
rarely is someone a position to thank
the academy without ever having a
produced credit so uh be enjoying that
uh
so thank you to the academy Joan Eric
Don and G Nichol uh the whole nickel
committee my mom told me to really make
the next few minutes interesting uh to
tell a story and not just turn it into a
bunch of thank yous but in my experience
the thank yous are the story here the
truth is that there have been many
versions of ojac developed over a period
of time that I've been told not to
mention out loud uh better that it
seemed like some perfect first draft
that burst out of my skull like Athena
in 12 point Courier font
um
but the reality is that this story
needed a lot of effort for me and I
needed the generosity of the many
wonderful people in my life who helped
make me into a writer who's still trying
to get better
um I want to thank my mom who can't be
here uh for reading the very first draft
and crying on the spot
um and I want to thank the many other
people whose feedback brought me to
tears uh I want to thank the mystery
Center for writers and UT Austin's RTF
screenwriting program especially Stuart
Kelvin for making me a writer period
and to my friends and mentors at USC a
big thank you to Michelle Steve and Leo
at Cape and everyone at Cape for
believing in this story at a time where
even I had my doubts
um to my dad who read to me every single
night to my incredible sister and
stepdad my cousins ums and tatas around
the world to my first reader on all
things Brittany uh and Myoma who
inspires so much of what I write you'll
find your way into every story
um but especially this one
this script is my Heritage uh born from
my time spent living and working in
Jakarta as an adult I used ojex to get
to and from my job every day learning
their stories is my Bahasa barely
improved they were the epitome of the
city to me motorcycle riding Specialists
with the skills to help jacquardens
navigate what might be the world's most
traffic and I've lived in DC and L.A
um
ojek is Park tribute to these real-life
action heroes and part tribute to my own
family who came from the jungles of
sulawesi to prosper in a city where
nothing grows swims or runs the elders
treasure the wealth that they've been
able to obtain here in Jakarta and the
young covet dreams of moving to Thailand
Europe and Beyond but they rarely ever
go the longer I stayed the more I
discovered jakarta's magnetism powered
by people devoted to having their whole
universe in a single spot uh when I got
back to the US and started writing ojac
became a story about my family and the
complex dynamics that make leaving the
people you love nearly impossible and
then hopefully told in the style of
befitting Jakarta loud fast bold and
full of living things crashing into each
other or getting out just in time
uh
in this scene
our protagonist good day reluctantly
meets his nerdo well brother bajo at
meliaboro the sort of nightclub in North
Jakarta that a guy like a day would
never frequent but he can't say no to
his little brother as beijio promises to
present him with an opportunity that
will make the most of good days
transporting talents as an oject and
hopefully help them both build a better
life thank you all
[Music]